hi guys congratulations on a beautiful
piece of cinema my question is for Ana
obviously this is a film that blends to
Universal magics fairytales and music
and we've already heard about your kind
of introduction to fairy tales but I'm
curious if you could share with us how
you discovered the magic of music and
what it is that excites you and makes
you enjoy it so much good such a huge
part of your career at the moment
obviously that's a hard question that's
like asking my discovery of oxygen water
and shelter those are all pretty good
yeah I mean my mother maintains that the
first song I ever sang was lady in red
and I [ __ ] hate that song so I don't
believe Bale my Christmas at all though
no technically a Christmas song in red
is very much a Christmas card but I mean
I think there were a number of people
who reported back to my mother from
school saying Anna won't stop singing
that kind of thing but you know those
those memories are like I can't remember
if I remember them or if I just think
that I do because I've been told about
them so many times to be totally honest
this I don't tell this story much
because it sounds sort of fake but I
really was always kind of attached to
the little red part because I saw the
piece so young and that's more in my
vocal range and being loud and bratty is
more in my wheelhouse than being open
and vulnerable but there was some reason
that I was trying to learn steps of the
palace for fun or something years ago
and I remember that being the first time
that I had looked at a piece of music
and thought and really understood or
began to understand the genius of
Sondheim because he writes your
performance into the melody and
you have this amazing opportunity to
work with someone and be elevated by
this performance there's never a part
where you're going oh god okay when the
third chorus comes back around like how
should I make that you know make sure
that that has life and energy you know
it's it was like I was playing with the
greatest tennis partner in the world and
it made it really difficult but it made
me do my best work so actually on the
steps of the palace because it see it
sounds fake it sounds like I'm kidding
it was one of the first pieces that made
me understand what music can do for you
emotionally
you